someone who listens to like what the
critics are gonna say or no I I did i
I've done that a couple I'd know I did
it once and I was this is true I'm
listen listening to NPR mm-hmm I have a
t-shirt on of the station I've donated
money to you you know you gave them
money they sent yeah sure yeah your
supporter yeah a t-shirt from Bangladesh
mm-hmm real cool NPR yeah
so the radio is on and these these
critics and they get ready to review a
movie that I know that I'm in I say to
myself oh I should turn this off but I
listen to it and this is what one of the
critics said as I was listening as I'm
wearing the t-shirt not sure about
wearing this yeah $500 to the station to
get this t-shirt for Baker - yeah when
it first critic says let's hope this is
the end of Zach Galifianakis career
really the second critic goes I hope
you're right yeah I took the t-shirt off
and I put it back on then one time this
is this friend of mine since me an NPR
link he ins me he emails me an NPR thing
and I click it on it's a video I don't
know NPR's doing a video I don't know
why they're the radio but Kyra's doll
it's a guy on NPR some low hard no I'm
just kidding yeah he follows the
paparazzi around for a day right mm-hmm
and the paparazzi gets a call hey we got
Zach Galifianakis at Rose cafe the
paparazzi go guy goes no thanks that's
coffee money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you